S FOR NYLANDER.
MATTHEWS DROPS IT DOWN.
TAVARES PULLS
MARNER.
IN THE FINAL MINUT
MARNER ACROSS.
THE GIVE AND GO PLAY.
MARNER IN
BOUNCED TO THE LINE.
KEPT ALIV
LEFT PAD ON IT.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT OO
GETS 40 GOALS FOR MOOSE JAW,
SIGNED AS A FREE AGENT ANDAD
AND DRIFT IT OUT TO
NET, BUT DECIDED TO
GO AHEAD ANDLILJIGREN OT
E
POINTS.
IT ROLLS TO
THE POWER PLAY SHOWING POST.
TAVARES BACK FOR MATTHEWS.
LET'S IT GO, SCORES! DOMI SHOOT.
NO
AUSTON MATTHEWSE FOR RIELLY.
NYLANDER.
F THE PENALTY'S
TAKEN, RIGHT THERE. AND FORCE CN
OUTLET TO ZACK KAS
BACKHAND SCORES!
AUSTON M AND MATTHEWS HAYES
DOUBLED DOWOWGOAL SATURDAY
AND THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS HAD 25
DIFFERENT PLAYERS SCORE THIS
E
MATTHEWS ANSWERS WIT
RIELLY.
SHOOTING.
SCORES!
TIPPED IN HUGHES.
OVER THE LINE
INSTEAD, 1-0 MAPLE LEAFS IN THE
EARLYMARNER'S SHOT DEFLECTED,
ANDERSEN WITH A SAFE,
NOW MATTHEWS SCORES ON THE ONE-
TIMER!  AND HE SCORES!
AND AUSTON MATTHEWS IS TIED FOR
THE LEAD LEAGUE IN  A GOAL,
BOLDUC.
FIALA ONE OF THE WILD's BEST
LINES AND GOT THEM ON THECORNER.
MATTHEWS KICKS IT FREE. GOAL
SCORING LEADER AGAIN, AS HE HAS
HIS THE STICK OF
PEARSON.
LILJEGREN FIRED THAT AND DEMKO
AND THEY GET THIS ONE AGAIN.SHO
SCORES!
AUSTON MATTHEWS STRIKES AGAINST,
SAVED BY BACK, MATTHEWS
PICKS IT UP, AUS ARE BEING THRON
AT HIM. BACKHANDER, CHOPPED
AT THERE BY KERFOOT.
NOW TO THE
HERE'S MITCHELL MARNER.
MATTHEWS! OF THE NET.
MATTHEWS HAD A CHANCE!
GIORDANO TO CLEAR.Y ALLEN INN
AND THE MAPLE LEAFS ARE GOING T
TO MATTHEWS,THE PUCK.
MATTHEWS CENTERS, BUNTING
ACROSS TO RIELLY.
RIELLY SHARP,
THEY HAVE WON THEIR FAIR SHARE
OF DRAWLS IN THE SECOND PERIOD.
>> Dave:'S MATTHEWS ON IT.
MATTHEWS ONE-TIMER AND THERE IT
MARNER JOINS MATTHEWS.
HE'S ON THE ATTACK.
DRIVING TO THE
NUMBER 58ZA, DENIED BY
NEDELJKOVIC.
UP TOP IT'S